visible from space the Okavango Delta is
Africa's largest remaining intact
wetland wilderness this shining Delta in
landlocked Botswana is the jewel of the
Kalahari more valuable than diamonds to
the world's largest diamond producer and
celebrated in 2014 as our planet's
1000th UNESCO World Heritage Site now
what you see here are the two major
tributaries the Crito and the Kabongo
disappearing up north into the
little-known Angolan highlands this is
the largest undeveloped River Basin on
the planet spanning an area larger than
California these vast undeveloped and
golden watersheds were frozen in time by
27 years of civil war in fact Africa's
largest tank battle since world war ii
was fought over a bridge crossing the
Okavango scuitto river there on the
right
disappearing off into the unknown into
the Terra the fin de mundo land at the
end of the earth as it was known by the
first Portuguese explorers in 2001 at
the age of 22 I took a job as head of
housekeeping at boontem Tiki Camp in the
Okavango Delta a patchwork mosaic of
channels floodplains lagoons and
thousands upon thousands of islands to
explore home to the largest remaining
population of elephants on the planet
rhinos are airlifted in c-130s to find
sanctuary in this wilderness lion
leopard hyena wild dog cheetah ancient
bear bad trees that stand like
cathedrals under the Milky Way here I
discovered something obvious wilderness
is our natural habitat - we need these
last wild places to reconnect with who
we really are we all seven billion of us
must
never forget we are a biological species
forever bound to this particular
biological world like the waves
connected to the ocean we cannot exist
apart from it a constant flow of atoms
and energy between individuals and
species around the world in the day and
out into the cosmos our fates are
forever connected to the millions of
species we rely on directly and
indirectly every day four years ago he
was declared that 50% of all wildlife
around the world had disappeared in just
40 years this is a mass stranding of
15,000 Volda biasts
that are witnessed in the Maasai Mara
two years ago this is definitely our
fault
by 2020 global wildlife populations are
projected to have fallen by a staggering
two-thirds we are the sixth extinction
because we left no safe space for
millions of species to sustainably
coexist
now since 2010 I have polled myself
eight times across the Okavango Delta to
conduct detailed scientific surveys
along a 200-mile 18 day research
transect now why am I doing this why am
i risking my life each year I'm doing
this because we need this information to
benchmark this near pristine wilderness
before upstream development happens
these are the whyyyy River Bushmen the
people of the Okavango Delta they've
taught me all I know about the mother
Okavango about presence in the wild our
shared pilgrimage across the Okavango
Delta each year in our Makarova dugout
canoes remembers millennia living in the
wild ten thousand years ago our entire
world was wilderness today wilderness is
all that remains of that world now gone
10,000 years ago we were as we are today
and modern dreaming intelligence unlike
anything seen before living in the
wilderness is that taught us to speak to
seek technologies like fire and stone
bow and arrow medicine and poison to
domesticate plan
an animal and allowing each other and
all living things around us we are these
last wildernesses every one of us of 80%
of our planet's land surface is now
experiencing measurable human impacts
habitat destruction and illegal wildlife
trade or decimating global wildlife
populations we urgently need to create
safe space for these wild animals so in
late 2014 we launched an ambitious
project to do just that explore and
protect by mid May 2015 we had pioneered
access through active minefields to the
undocumented source Lake of the quita
River this otherworldly place an ancient
untouched wilderness by the 21st of May
we had launched the Okavango mega
transect in seven dugout canoes 1,500
miles 121 days later of poling paddling
and intensive research got us across the
entire River Basin to Lake cow in the
Kalahari Desert 480 kilometers past the
Okavango Dalton my entire world
became the water every ripple Eddy lily
pad and current any sign of danger every
sign of life I imagine millions of sweat
bees choking the air around you
flesh-eating bacteria the constant
threat of a landmine going off or an
unseen hipa capsizing your mokoro these
are the scenes moments after hip I did
just that thrusting its tusks through
the hull of my butt you can see the two
holes punch winds in the base of that of
the hull absolutely terrifying and
completely my fault many many Portage's
tree blockages and capsizes and rocky
Rapids you're living on rice and beans
bathing in a bucket of cold water and
paddling a marathon 68 hours every
single day after 121 days of this I've
forgotten the pin numbers to my bank
accounts and logins for social media a
complete systems reboot you ask me now
if I miss it and I'll tell you I am
still there now why do we need to save
places we hardly ever go why do we need
to save places where you have to risk
your life to be
now I'm not a religious or particularly
spiritual person but in the wild
I believe I've experienced the
birthplace of religion standing in front
of an elephant
far away from anywhere is the closest I
will ever get to God Moses Buddha
Muhammad Jesus the Hindu teachers
prophets and mystics all went into the
wilderness up into the mountains into
the deserts to sit quietly and listen
for those secrets that were to guide
their societies for millennia I go into
the Okavango on my mokoro you must join
me one day over fifty percent of the
remaining world ernest is unprotected a
huge opportunity a chance for us all we
need to act with great urgency
since the 2015 megatron sect we have
explored all major rivers of the
Okavango River Basin covering a
life-changing 4,000 miles of detailed
research transects on our dugout canoes
and our fat tire Martin bikes we now
have 57 top scientists rediscovering
what we call the Okavango Zambezi water
tower
this vast post-war wilderness worth
undocumented sauce lakes unnamed
waterfalls and what is Africa's largest
remaining neon bur woodland we have now
discovered 24 new species to science and
hundreds of species not known to be
there this year we start the process
with the Angolan government to establish
one of the largest systems of protected
areas in the world to preserve the
Okavango Zambezi water tower we have
been exploring downstream this
represents water security for millions
of people and more than half of the
elephants remaining on this planet there
is no doubt this is the biggest
conservation opportunity in Africa in
decades over the next 10 to 15 years we
need to make an unprecedented investment
in the preservation of wilderness around
the world to me
preserving wilderness is far more than
simply protecting ecosystems that clean
the water we drink and create the air we
breathe preserving wilderness protects
our basic human right to be wild our
basic human rights to explore thank you
[Applause]